[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to minecraft live 2021
i'm your host and chief storyteller of
mojang studios lydia winters
we have an exciting show for you today
filled with all things minecraft you'll
vote a new mob into the game hear what's
happening in minecraft dungeons learn
how to design and play with your own
minecraft mob find out the next
minecraft update and much much more
seriously though
we have a packed show for you
the best part is that you get to hear
everything directly from the cool humans
making it and they will give you the
inside knowledge that no one outside of
mojang studios knows our best kept
secrets
until we tell you all of them today so
let's do it
our social team will be tweeting
throughout the show and want to know
what you think about everything we
announce hang out with us here and also
there
last year we announced quite an
anticipated update the caves in the
cliffs update we've seen all the
incredible things you've done with caves
in coast part one and can't wait to see
what you do with part two agnes and
henrik are here to give us a peek into
the surprising development process for
caves and cliffs part two hi agnes hi
henry hello agnes how are you feeling
i'm super happy to be here i'm excited
very excited so excited and henrik it's
your first time on the minecraft last
year it is it's not your first time
though right it is not my first time
you two are gonna tell us about caves
and cliffs part two and the thing that i
think is the most amazing is how
involved and how essential the community
was to making it yes yeah this update
changes basically everything about about
the world generation in the game so
we've added like massive uh mountains
massive caves and
um
it's been really hard to kind of uh
balance that because we want to add all
this new cool stuff
but when people are playing the game we
also want them to be able to encounter
like the old familiar stuff so this
balancing act is really hard so as
designers and developers when we you
know test the stuff we built how do we
know if it's any good right how do we
know if it's better so we've needed a
lot of help and we've definitely gotten
it so we've been shipping snapshots
betas every week and and people have
been playtesting and giving us feedback
and it's it's just been wonderful it
feels kind of like their
colleagues helping us to build this
great game that's amazing and you have a
like an amazing example of someone who
took a lot of time given yes
yeah
for example on on
a a player gave i tweeted at me
this wonderful big picture showing like
across different snapshots um in the
same location what changed across across
different snapshots and and i'm offered
some opinions on that and some feedback
and this kind of stuff takes a lot of
time to do it's it's it's it's research
that the users are doing for us and we
get a lot of this stuff and it just it
just saves time and um and that's time
that we can use of course to make the
game better that's so amazing it truly
is i mean this is like the biggest
update we've ever done and we couldn't
have done it without a community
oh that's incredible and i know you were
kind of nervous when you decided to
split the update and like tell everyone
about that
yes i mean that's a like it's a very big
decision and we took it together as a
team but yes when it was time to
announce it it was quite scary but we
thought the best thing is just to be
transparent because like as we know like
minecraft is crafted together with the
community and then it's good if we just
are as honest as we possibly can and
then when we did the announcement
announce it everyone was just you know
so caring and understanding and it like
yeah it shows we have the most beautiful
community so yeah thank you we
absolutely do and it was so nice as a
team to be able to not rush it since
this change is so big to be able to do
it properly and take the time and
really do it well so we're we're super
thankful that we got so strong support
for it that's awesome and i mean
sometimes during the development process
like things change and you decide you
want things to be bigger and better
which kind of moves them to a different
timeline and i know we have one of those
today yeah we do so we have been working
quite a lot on like the deep dark the
warden and the skull sensor and we're so
excited about this and we know everyone
is and
so it's got to be bigger because we
really want to do this right and do it
with super high quality but that that's
also the reason to that we moved it to
the next update
instead and we're gonna talk about the
next update at the end of the show right
so we're gonna show both some new things
from the deep dark and some other new
things so that's exciting so we'll move
the deep dark feature set into the next
update which will be after caves and
close part two and we're gonna look at
that later in the show you're gonna get
to see some really cool stuff from
brandon now henrik and agnes you two are
working with an awesome team of
developers and this was like quite a
technical challenge so we have an inside
look at
sort of
a lot that went into caves and close
part two yep let's watch it
the best part of my job i think it's
just creating a game
i want to make people happy
in the new update my i've been primarily
focusing on creating the mountains and
also putting everything together in the
new generation of the world so that's
the caves and the mountains and
everything in between
when i started this project about a year
ago i knew almost nothing about world
generation and i learned so much
and it's really been a team effort java
and bedrock together
in this update my role is to bring to
life the k part
and together with our colleague who work
on the mountains we
present to you the cliffs and the caves
update
one of the inspirations for the caves is
the songdongs cave systems in vietnam
because that was one of the largest cave
systems in the world
and i feel so proud of it because i came
from vietnam and we get to
use these cave systems in my country and
put it into the game so i felt so proud
whenever
we think about the caves
my job is to find what works slow in
minecraft and try to optimize it
the new update changes how the world
looks a lot and it also affects
performance quite a lot
the best part about my job is just
finding something which can give a big
benefit and then just seeing how fps
improves or how
frame time graph looks much better after
the change
i would say the coolest part about my
job is all of the wonderful colleagues
that i get to work with and they really
inspire me teach me and motivate me to
to be a better version of myself every
day
we put in a lot of time and effort into
this update and i hope that it will
inspire and excite our community it
feels like
it's a whole new game
what a great team you have the best team
and now we have been working on kids
like this part 2 it's been so beautiful
to see how everyone collaborated like
all the different roles like bedrock
developers java developers designers
artists sound and so on yeah it's been
so good when you get a diverse group of
people together in a room like that even
if it's a digital room i guess then yeah
and all focus on one thing like this it
feels like there's there's no problem
you can't solve plus it's it's fun
that's amazing and then you add our
community they're doing bud bug tracking
they're just everywhere giving us notes
and feedback and telling us what's
working so you add that to an amazing
team and it's really incredible we
really want actually to highlight
everyone that helps us with the public
bike tracker we have so so many players
report bugs and then we also have the
moderators and helpers and they help us
so much like categorizing finding
duplicates asking for additional
information and it's extraordinary
helpful we have a really amazing
community
now you two have been and and actually
the whole team has been just
kind of sharing images and seeds as
you're finding things and you put
together
some really awesome worlds for us to
look at
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow
they're beautiful
yeah what's interesting about this is
when you look at that video like
initially the plan was just big
mountains and natural looking cool
mountains and caves but as we started
working on it the scope kind of grew
because we realized that we need to
change all the terrain to make this all
fit together but but once we started
seeing that work and it was so fun to
see how the team started realizing that
we're really onto something this is
going to be great and seeing that
inspiration spread and then also spread
out to our community through the
snapshots has been really fun yeah and
we have been play testing a lot and
we're like we couldn't stop playing this
because we're distracted
and it
feels so inspiring and that's what we
want to do with minecraft we want to
inspire everyone to play minecraft in
their own way and like we really feel
that this new world generation inspires
like going on adventure building it's
telling stories it's very exciting
that's amazing and i mean so you make
all these changes but then obviously we
have so many players who've been playing
for so long i mean the two of you have
worlds that are like 10 years old and i
just love the approach you took to
keeping everything really safe for
players who have existing worlds yes
it's very important for us to be
respectful to players worlds and
like minecraft should be a game you can
trust because we know that it works and
it will work for many many years then
you can spend like all this love and
time on your minecraft world so in case
necklace part 2 we have actually done
two things mainly to make sure that
everything works well and the first
thing is blending
so as you can see in the picture here to
the left we don't have blending so then
when you update your old world to the
new world generation it would just be
like an ugly edge but now with blending
it's actually all smooth and pretty
that's beautiful that makes a huge
difference and henrik i know the other
part uh you want to show us with your
own world yeah so um what happens if you
open your old world with with a new
version of minecraft and
i took a look at what happens in my old
world which i've had for like 10 years
playing with with friends and
family and uh let's take a look so
that's there it is all the old stuff we
built 10 years ago but that's what
happens when you when you open the world
in 1.18 so it basically generates new
caves beneath the old areas
and the idea is to create the illusion
that that was there the whole time we
just you know we just didn't go there
until now and wow look look what i found
yeah don't look henrik there's so many
spoilers there under your world so many
questions i i was quinting okay good
that's like the first thing i'm gonna do
and i
update is just like digging straight up
well not straight down actually
but i'm gonna see what's under my face
that's so cool i just love that it adds
so much to the existing worlds that our
players have and so you're keeping them
safe and adding a lot to it and that's
also an important thing we don't want to
force players to have to pick between
just the new or just old so we want them
to be able to experience both things in
in the same world that's amazing
throughout the show we're going to have
creator questions and you two get to
have the first one
right will jabba and bedrock departure
at the same time
yes the plan is to release this on java
bedrock at the same time and also to
ship it with what we call seed parity
and that's what does that mean so um
seed is this name for the magic number
that is used to determine how your whole
world looks like so every world is
unique and that's driven by the seed and
when you create a new world it gets a
randomly a generated seed but if you dig
that seed up if you really like what you
see you're like wow this world is
wonderful i want to share it with my
friends you can dig up that number and
share with others and then if they open
a new world with that c they'll see the
same thing
but what's new for this update is that
that also works between bedrock and java
that's amazing so if you create a world
in java and you think it's beautiful you
want to share with others anyone who who
opens the world with that seed
regardless of which edition they're
playing we'll see essentially almost
exactly the same thing
yeah i mean it's almost identical and
it's a thing in the community you know
you find a super cool location and you
share it like look at this world i found
and before you couldn't do that with
players on the other edition but now
everyone can just share cool places
together and i think that's really nice
it's really amazing i mean when you find
these amazing epic things in caves and
close part 2 you obviously want to be
able to share them so seed parody is
huge i think everyone's going to be so
excited about it so we're not 100 there
yet but close very similar
details will be different feed almost
parodies
that's it that's why
so i know everyone is anxiously
including myself waiting for this update
when do we get it
so it's actually almost done so we're
gonna release it in a month for two that
is amazing thank you so much agnes and
henrik thank you
caves and cliffs part 2 will be coming
to a screen near you in one to two
months and speaking of screams soon
there will be another place to play
minecraft on november 2nd minecraft
comes to xbox game pass for pc
minecraft it's a game all about
togetherness and teamwork let's take a
look at some of minecraft's most
terrific teams
zombies and the drowned
maybe not the best example let's try
another
cobblestone and mossy cobblestone a
relationship that's truly rock solid
oh dear
how about steve and creeper
okay maybe not stephen
not there
not them either
that's got to hurt
you realize this is going out live right
if we don't find a great example of
minecraft togetherness soon what's that
goat
you've got the best example of
togetherness yet
okay this better be good minecraft
bedrock edition and minecraft java
edition finally coming together for
no that's not right
absolutely not
that's the ticket
minecraft bedrock edition and minecraft
java edition are coming to xbox game
pass for pc
we debated which edition to add to the
service and decided why not add both
that means game pass for pc will be the
only way to get bedrock and java in one
place
convenient perhaps a little too
convenient
in any case starting in november you can
play the original blockbuster its
cross-play supporting cousin and a
cart-load of other games with game pass
for pc
excellent point goat game pass does have
pc games
and personally i can't wait to play
those pc games with my two best friends
[Music]
ah
the sweet smell of togetherness
[Music]
hello minecrafters of the world i'm vu
bui and i'm back yet again to help guide
you through this year's incredibly
important and potentially life-altering
vote remember the phantom for an amazing
mob that will be added to minecraft for
those of you who haven't been a part of
minecraft live before here's how it
works our developers came up with three
different mobs that they think could
potentially be a great addition to
minecraft for a variety of reasons but
you the community of minecraft players
around the world get to decide which one
gets further developed and brought into
the game in a future update and which
ones will live on only in our hearts as
what could have been
like you little baby
i'll never forget you
moving on the actual winner of last
year's intense mob vote was none other
than the glow squid if you haven't run
into these majestic creatures swimming
around under the stars on a clear night
you are really missing out but that was
last year and this is now so here's what
you need to do we have three mobs for
you to choose from and there will be two
rounds of voting the first round of
course will include all three mobs but
one will get voted out in the second
round there will only be the two
remaining mobs then just one winner in
the end as in previous years the vote
will happen on twitter so if you don't
already have an account you'll need to
quickly make one and if you do have an
account make sure you're logged in then
when i tell you it's time to vote go to
the minecraft twitter account and check
out the live voting poll with all three
mob options
pick the one you want to see added to
minecraft and click to cast your vote
that's it it's like super easy well the
clicking part is easy the choosing part
considerably more difficult
now that you know what to do let's go
over your options and who better to talk
about our three potential new mobs than
someone who is tiny in size but never in
heart the one the only tiny ends
hey tiny ends so can you help by telling
what
i can't hear you hold on oh i'll come up
to the surface
okay
we'll we'll just wait
can you hear me now
what
i still can't hear you hold on so
impatient
a little testy
oh
tiny ends you made it can you tell our
viewers all about this year's mobs
i'm actually very busy i lost tiny agnes
again i had retraced my steps and now i
have to go all the way back down there
oh i'm sorry about that
but don't worry don't worry i know
someone who can fill in for me
great thanks
oh okay bye tiny ends
jens
you're here hi volk hello hello welcome
thank you i guess tiny yen sent you
while he looks for tiny agnes once again
exactly exactly it's a it's a tough
tough job it really is
well since you're here can you please
tell everyone all about this year's mobs
absolutely
so as you already mentioned the team
came up with three lovely creatures that
we believe that players will enjoy
interacting with and
they are the glare
the lay and the copper gold those all
sound really cool absolutely
and
to begin with we have the glare which is
a it's a
creature that flies around and
doesn't really like dark areas because
he knows that in dark areas there will
might be monster spawn yes so
naturally it goes to those areas and
gets really grumpy about it
and that is to bring that a player's
attention so that
the problem can be fixed okay um
and
we are
thinking about ideas that in certain
circumstances
the glare may even help you light up
these areas
to solve your
monster spawning problems the glare
sounds amazing i'm ready to vote claire
now yes but then we have the la which is
also a flying lovely creature that loves
music and who doesn't nice nice sounds
and if you give it an item it will start
looking for similar items
lying around and bring them to you okay
and if you also play on a note block it
will drop the items on the application
instead that's useful yes and we imagine
that
players can maybe use this to make the
la help you with i don't know sorting
items or
clearing up areas i think
there are many possibilities okay so
vote alay i get it yes but then we have
the copper golem
and as the name implies it's a it's a
golem made out of copper so it's an
excellent use for copper and
it will also like interact with you and
since it's made out of copper it will
over time oxidize and
maybe like turn into a statue
but don't worry you can de-oxidize it
using an axe or it actually carries
around the lightning rod on its head so
it will a lightning strike can also
deoxidize it and wow in addition
it loves pressing
buttons a little bit randomly uh is
specifically copper buttons but it
randomly presses yes so
that can also be used in
some interesting contraptions we believe
that's amazing so copper golem lay glare
all sound good how do people choose i
think it's going to be quite difficult
but you've given them a lot to think
about so i i think
people will figure out what they like
the most yes well thank you so much jens
for coming by
i have now a creator question for you
hello
okay those three questions i think
everyone who wants to know the answer of
yeah
well
ideas and inspiration can come from many
places sometimes it just
spontaneously appears when you're
walking around in the park or
often like you play other games watching
movies or playing minecraft and
the community is also a great help they
have so many ideas and they do so many
fun things
so we we have a
lot of ideas to work with and we need to
figure out like which ones do we
do we want to do next and a good way of
doing that is actually playing in the
game and see which areas that can be
improved and
so
i lost my training i mean there's so
many different ways that these ideas
come and that's really exciting to hear
so
when the community votes on a mob today
that mob is going to move forward
towards being in minecraft like how
finished already is that mob or is there
a lot of work to do well of course we
have the big
concept that we wanted
to do but once we have the mob in the
game and see how it interacts with the
areas and other mobs and items that's
when you kind of find the last magic
little details to make it really great i
like hearing about the last magic
details well thanks jens you've given
everyone a lot to think about
all right
now you know what your options are and
if you already knew you know a little
more about them soon i'll let you know
when the first voting round goes live
for now let's take a look at something
pretty fantastic coming to minecraft
that you don't even have to vote on
earlier this week lydia spoke with fanny
and quinn from our awesome creator team
over in redmond to get a first look at
some interesting things they've been
working on
each year we show you some of the cool
new things made by our creators for
minecraft marketplace this year we're
going to do that and show you how to
start creating minecraft things yourself
i finally made my first mob
it's very weird fanny and quinn are here
to tell us all about how we can all
become creators hi fanny and quinn hello
lydia hey lydia
it's so great to be here like just so
exciting to talk about our creators and
what a better place to do it and
surrounded by the art that they have
created i know i walked onto the set and
i was like oh my god those are jolly
craft skins those are cupcake brianna
that's cost studios it was so cool just
seeing all of their skins and worlds and
concepts all on the wall
they are really amazing i mean the
creativity from our creators
those names that makes sense now it's
it's just mind-blowing
before we get too far in though we
should probably explain to everyone
what what is a creator yeah of course so
creator is really
anybody who makes anything in minecraft
you know whether you're doing skins
textures worlds terraforming ui
and even for me like people that are
making mods and add-ons and you know
that kind of more developer type those
are creators too definitely for me the
way that i always like to think about it
is that creator is anyone that makes
something minecraft and then shares it
with someone else and that can be like
little mac sharing it with their friends
at school or that could be a team of
creators that sell something in the
marketplace and then everything in
between right and our mission really is
to empower all of them to make whatever
their imagination is telling them to do
we want to really give you all the means
documentation tools to be able to do
whatever you want to do yeah it's just
such a cool thing to be able to work on
that everybody can be a creator
that is so cool and fanny you mentioned
tools i think it's so interesting your
team is actually building things
that creators use to
build things on top of
like what is your favorite tool that
you've made oh god that is such a hard
question we have so many but i'm going
to be a little bit selfish for a second
and just pick one that i worked on
recently like as a manager i really get
the chance to actually write code which
i love doing and this time we had a game
jam and i actually picked a
creator community request
which is like implement a damage command
that will help you like do cool effects
with other mobs and i just worked with
the designer and we created this
together and i'm so excited to know that
the team is actually now taking my code
and it's going to ship it for real very
excited about that yeah that's just so
cool that you're able to do something
just in a game jam and then it turns
into something real that our creators
can use for me my favorite is the
structure animation last year we shipped
a map called suburbia by jiggerbob that
is basically this world that you can you
know manage your city create plots for
commercial residential balance your
economy and every single time you place
one of those plots it animates layer by
layer by layer adding just this
immersiveness and polish to the map that
just makes it i don't know above and
beyond
that's so cool i mean so many of our
creators are using the innovative tools
that you've made to just like expand
what they're working on and we have some
awesome examples of that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i love how many examples there were of
creators just using those tools in all
different ways
what's that like for you to see fanny
when your team you've all been working
on making those things for our creators
it's definitely one of my favorite parts
of like working with creators you just
give them one tool or two and they will
make these crazy amazing things like
many time i see their creations like how
do they even do that like i know they're
using our tools but i don't know how
they did that it's so crazy it's it's
mind-blowing sometimes just what they're
able to do with just the small little
things that we give them
that's really really cool and we have a
creator question for the two of you
hey everyone i'm ey stream a minecraft
youtuber and i've got a question for you
are these awesome features just for
people who have experience in modding or
creating content and if we wanted to how
do people learn more about these
features
it's such a great question because the
answer is no they aren't just for you
know advanced modders or people that
have been in the community for a long
time we actually just launched a new
website we call it learning portal it's
on minecraft.net creator and on that
site it basically links out to all of
our resources to how to learn how to
become a creator learn how minecraft
content creation works it also links out
to our brand new documentation site that
allows you to just go super deep into
you know learning the components and
learning entities and then the coolest
thing that we added which is how we made
our mobs is we use the minecraft entity
wizard which is created by janis and
it's a blockbench plugin that allows
like super easy creation of mobs that
you can add your own minecraft game
hello everyone my name is janis i'm a
software developer and minecraft content
creator in 2017 i started to create my
own 3d modelling program called
blockbench
the program is all about creating boxy
pixely models which makes it perfect for
the minecraft art style
today blockbench supports many minecraft
formats ranging from bedrock edition
add-ons to java edition resource packs
and mods the program is used by
minecraft creators all around the world
to create models animations and player
skins
almost all 3d models you see on the
minecraft marketplace were made in
blockbench and it was even used to
design some of the new vanilla mobs such
as the goat and the axolotl
this summer i've collaborated with
mojang to create a new plugin for
blockbench the plugin makes it super
easy to get started with add-on creation
by generating everything you need for a
custom entity in just a few clicks
i'm going to demonstrate the process by
making a simple grizzly bear
to install the plugin i'm heading to
file plugins available search for the
minecraft entity wizard and press
install
that brings up this handy shortcut on
the start screen
let's go i'm going to pick a preset that
looks similar to the grizzly like this
polar bear and i'll use the same for the
behavior
okay now the addon is created on your
computer now let's start customizing our
model using blockbench
for this example because we already have
a bare model i'm just going to recolor
the model
of course you could also change the
whole model to turn it into something
entirely different
like this butterfly that i made and the
space on the vanilla bed
[Music]
okay this looks good now i'm going to
press save and switch over to
minecraft i can find our new grizzly
bear pack in the behavior pack section
and simply enable it
this will automatically enable the
resource pack as well
now let's check out the entity in-game i
just need to grab a spawn egg from the
inventory and use it
and here's our grizzly bear
[Music]
have fun creating it's free and works on
all platforms
[Music]
i already told you all that i made a mob
but actually all three of us made mobs
because we wanted to showcase that
anyone can be a creator
so fanny tell us about your adorable mob
that you made thank you yes i i was so
excited to know that blockbunch was a
thing because i immediately thought i
need to add my dogs to minecraft i
really really love them and i was just
so excited like blockbunch made it very
easy for me to just obsess over every
single detail like every pixel was like
does that look like my dog and then i
also modified the geometry especially
the tails uh to look like the exact
twist that my dogs have i really
obsessed a lot and i was very happy
especially when i was able to add my own
animation i'm definitely not an art
person and i just made it so that it
like wiggles their tail when they're
receiving i i was just so happy to be
able to do that they turned out so good
i thought it was super cute that you're
able to get both them in there thank you
so me being kind of uh you know born in
the pacific northwest outdoorsy i mean
i'm wearing flannel on the on the stage
i wanted to kind of pull something from
that nature so i made evelyn evergreen
she's this kind of cute little uh
evergreen tree that you maybe see you
know walking around the deep forest
kind of fantasy driven that i've
animated the arms and the legs just
these little stick legs that kind of
walk around uh just to add something you
know kind of you know kind of cute and
cool to the forests her eyes are really
staring right into my soul i love it i
would love to just happen upon evelyn in
the forest
so i went in totally different direction
from the two of you i know quinn you
built your mob from scratch
fanny you built yours on top of a wolf i
built mine on top of something i did not
animate i just wanted to do the
beginners course of block bench
and so i made something very near and
dear to my florida heart
with a twist which is what i'm calling
an alolatal an axolotl and an alligator
kind of like a little dragon it does
look like a little dragon it's a pretty
good uh pretty good mash up there i
think it's great
yeah i thought an alligator and axolotl
would be super innovative when added
together but it does just look like a
dragon but i'm okay with that because i
am a creator now based on your
definition because i made that and i
showed it to all of you
which
seeing something that you make
in a game that you've played you know
for me for 11 years
it was it was amazing it is so rewarding
really to be able to just do that so we
encourage you all to try it like if
someone that like paint is the only
skill that i have like i know everyone
can do it so please go install
blockbench and try it out like we would
be so so incredibly like proud to just
see everything that you have built we
would love to see it yeah it's available
on all the platforms and just you know
post them on twitter post them on
wherever you do and you know we'll
probably run across some of those and we
love seeing them oh i can't wait to see
what everyone else creates and i mean i
think that our our mobs are definitely
ready for the mob vote next year so we
don't even have to work on anything else
these three are perfect i'm gonna have
to talk to the team about that
so we're not professional creators
obviously by our mobs even though
they're lovely but quinn you get to work
with people
who this is their full-time job making
minecraft content for marketplace what
is that like
it's something that i'm just immensely
proud of like being able to see
so many people engage in the marketplace
and allow that you know allow creators
to become full-time minecraft content
creators as their careers
i mean i think it's incredible too
because the marketplace doesn't just
support you know these huge studios but
we also have really small independent
creators that you know make just texture
packs
or like shallow quin schematics that's
just a family on the on the west coast
that makes their own worlds and the fact
that the marketplace can support all of
them and you know make it their
full-time jobs is something that is just
so cool
there's so much new content that our
creators have made that we put together
a video with some of our favorites from
this past year
[Music]
it almost feels like a dream that i'm
making a living making content for the
marketplace
is the best job that i could possibly
ask for
[Music]
oh
[Music]
we just got to see some amazing
reactions from the fans and people love
the map and that's just so heartwarming
and lovely to see and it really does put
a smile on our faces
[Music]
[Music]
the thing i like most about creating
inside of minecraft is the community
that's been built up around it
there's so many
amazing creative people
and it's been a privilege to be able to
meet and work with so many
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
we're kicking things off with the
announcement of the
we're gonna tell you
right now
they update aquatic
village and feel it
seriously like i'm so excited peace bees
let's look at some bees
to finally have nether update
holiday update will have the cats pandas
bamboo and scaffolding caves and cliffs
update
david nissagendy
[Music]
i am the one that gets to decide how
difficult the bosses are
the results of the first vote are in
the winner is tiger
mountains
it's the glow squid
this is your chance to have a say in
what goes into minecraft
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
go go go go go
[Music]
what should i do now
[Music]
moppy
[Applause]
ten years ago i stepped on the minecon
stage for the first time
i still get nervous and excited every
single time i'm on this stage but mostly
i feel incredibly honored to be in front
of you
i hope what you see and feel from each
of us at mojang studios is our passion
for minecraft and our gratitude to all
of you in our amazing community
okay now before i get way too even more
sappy than i was let's head over to moo
and hear more about the adorable mobs
that you must pick between
here we go it's almost time to vote
before we do though let's take a quick
look at your choices once more
we have the glare a mob that lets
players know when they're in an area
that's dark enough for monsters you can
bring it with you and it will fly to
dark areas when it gets grumpy you'll
know that it's dark enough for monsters
to spawn
then there's the alley if you give it an
item it will collect matching ones for
you it also loves music so if there's a
note block nearby that's where we'll
drop these items for you and finally the
copper golem a little golem that you
yourself can make out of copper they
oxidize over time and will eventually
freeze into statues they love spending
their time randomly pressing copper
buttons which would also be added to the
game if the copper golem wins the vote
so those are your choices and they are
all so amazing how will you choose jens
gave us a lot to think about and now you
need to decide which mob you think you'd
enjoy the most during your time playing
minecraft any of them would be useful
but choose your favorite and go vote for
it now yes that's right the poll is now
open to cast your vote make sure you're
logged into your twitter account go to
the minecraft twitter account and find
the freshly launched poll with all three
choices don't forget to click on the mob
you most want to play minecraft with you
can do it right now after the first
round of votes i'll check back in with
you so we can open the final round
[Music]
greetings my name is narrator and i'm
the star of the minecraft youtube
channel and i'm marilla i'm the actual
star of the minecraft youtube channel
we're here to tell you about all the
excellent shows you can watch on our
channel subscribe tomorrow don't you
mean subscribe today
no
[Music]
how do you spell minecraft
what even is minecraft these are just
some of the questions you can ask our
studio's brightest minds on ask mojang
we've actually received a question for
us just now
do you think making a video game is the
easiest thing in the world no
literally no one thinks that well i did
until i started watching this
informative series that goes behind the
blocks of every part of minecraft
dungeons development do they show the
footage of you tearfully begging to be
put in the game
maybe in series three
meet a minecrafter interview some of the
most incredible members of the minecraft
community
they asked me to appear on it but i was
too busy being young and cool and
attractive and not lying okay
with so much happening in the world of
minecraft it can be easy to lose track i
myself only recently learned that blocks
have been added to the game
subscribe to our channel and you'll be
the first to see our announcements
trailers for new updates upcoming games
and the exciting future of minecraft
are you sure that's the right footage
finally this is our peerless show that
tells you minecraft's most scandalous
secrets
every month we are out of
oh time not we still have a few seconds
left have a great minecraft live
everyone no
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and only watch my
now let's welcome laura to talk all
about minecraft dungeons hi laura hi
so you have a pretty cool job at mojang
studios yeah i think i have the coolest
job it's sometimes difficult to believe
but i'm the lead designer of minecraft
dungeons and that means that i get to
decide a lot of small things and details
and bring a lot of ideas to the table so
hopefully make the game a bit better
that does sound cool you and the
dungeons team have been working so hard
recently and you've recently had a
couple of really cool releases yeah yeah
it's been crazy uh we recently released
to steam
and i did something that they never
recommend you to do but i did it anyway
and i read the
reviews
and uh
yeah it's dangerous yeah it was but it
was so positive it was so full of
excitement and love for the game and
yeah we were so so proud to see how much
the community loves it so yeah we were
very happy and also this week we've
released the spookier fall update
which brings back a lot of spooky
modifiers to the game uh gear a new cape
a new pet and there's my new favorite
armor which has a spoon steering in your
head i love that one yeah it it it's
lovely i like it so much a lot of fun to
stare at while you're playing but it
might distract you a little
hopefully not too much
so
those just came out but we also have
some new and exciting things to look at
yeah that haven't come out yet yes let's
check it out
huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that video is so exciting yeah i love
that trailer so much it has so many
details
so there's a lot going on in that video
and a lot to talk about but why don't we
start with now the dlc is done
what are seasonal adventures right yeah
now that we are over with the story of
the orb of dominance we sat together
with our friends at double 11 and we
started working on seasonal adventures
which are a new way for the player to
progress through the game and increasing
ranks gather points and hopefully get
cool rewards at the end that sounds
amazing yeah so how long do they last
right
seasonal adventures although the name is
seasonal
will be infinite technically okay so for
for instance say we release seasonal
adventure number two you will always be
able to go back to seasonal adventure
number one gather some rewards there go
back to number two gather some rewards
there so it's a bit up to you what you
decide to do with it that's amazing so
it just lasts forever you get the new
content and you still have the old
content all the content and speaking of
content what are some of these new
things that players can unlock right
yeah we added tons of new rewards that
are completely new to the minecraft
universe uh somewhat some new uh we have
tons of new pets uh we have things like
the duck and the fox and i am so in love
with all of them we have flares which
are new vfx that you can apply to your
character so whenever you drink a potion
or you beat an enemy you get to show off
a little bit and get some shininess
there
also we got in some emotes which are
these little dances or literal
expressions you can do with your
character show off a little yeah exactly
and have some fun with your friends why
not like like we see here having a party
also we added tons of new capes because
everyone loves capes and tons of new
skins
just in case we were missing a lot of
skins yeah
that's a ton of skins yes well now we
have a question from a minecraft creator
right
hey strawberry17 here and i have a
question will there be free content
included as a part of seasonal
adventures
[Music]
the answer is yes
we always try to make sure there's
content for everyone regardless so for
seasonal adventures it'll always be a
free track and a track you can pay for
so there'll be different rewards in each
and you'll be able to get whichever you
want at any time so yeah we wanted to
cater everyone that's great
so how do you earn rewards
right you will be able to get adventure
points all throughout the game uh
meaning that doing the regular stuff you
do you'll get them like say you beat a
daily trial at the end of the daily
trial you get adventure points also we
implemented new weekly challenges so
we'll ask you like this week if you beat
100 zombies you'll get extra adventure
that's a lot of zombies yeah but people
do it so fast i'm always so impressed um
and also the best way to get adventure
points is in the tower
okay the tower which we have not spoken
about no so what is the tower the tower
is another free single player feature
that we've added to camp so you'll be
able to see the gigantic tower in the
camp i love how it turned out
and it is a space with 30 different
floors each floor harder than the one
before and you'll get to fight in arena
mobs you'll get to fight bosses
you'll get to meet some new tower
inhabitants and yeah hopefully explore
around and be able to test your skill so
you will start with a completely blank
character from the bottom and you'll be
able to find new gear as you progress
okay so yeah the floors get more
difficult your character gets stronger
and
you can test your skill that sounds
really fun so let's take a look at some
live gameplay of the tower right now and
for that we have jp hi jp hello
how do you like my throne i think you
stole that throat from the arch illager
i think he stole it from me
stuff let's go loot the tower nice
so what are we seeing here lauda right
so we've prepared some special floors to
showcase here so this is an example of a
very early floor in the tower so if you
see jp's tower avatar uh has very little
amount of gear and yeah you'll be always
have the context that you're high up in
the tower right so cool yeah
we also wanted to make sure that
the tower was this whimsical magical
space so
yeah we have a boat we have a river why
not
so you'll be able to find a ton of
magical spaces and
new characters to meet
so yeah this level is quite easy as you
can see
uh since it's very early yeah jp's doing
really well yeah exactly oh and we can
see a sneak peak up there in that
balcony that's uh our tower keeper very
cool yeah that's a character that will
guide you through the tower and yeah
we'll
guide you around and oh wow jf he did
really well yeah we were so fast
yeah so
each of these levels
generates itself but you can come back
for up to two weeks and replay the same
thing right yeah our tower runs will be
seated uh and they will change every two
weeks meaning that for two weeks you'll
be able to learn what happens in every
floor so say uh i reach floor five and i
get defeated at floor five so then next
time around i'll remember ah i should
have chosen a different weapon and then
i bet i could have done it so yeah you
can share that those tips with your
friends and you can learn together how
to go through the tower yeah practice
and get better exactly all right let's
give jp a real challenge now we're gonna
go up the tower to a much higher floor
right you ready jp let's do it
right so here we've prepared an example
of what a harder floor could look like
so
we try to add new exciting combinations
of mobs that we've never had before
so jp is right now fighting jungle mobs
but there'll be
ice mob together with them and there'll
be some new mobs here you can see some
tower raids
that spawn fire in different new
combinations we also will have
tower guards which are extremely bulky
birds we even have a guest in the mix
and
jp is getting
sniped by it so
we're getting yeah that's a tower guard
right there so yeah we're getting tons
of new combinations and
new ways to experience the game and
defeat mobs and find strategies and gas
looks really difficult yes yes it is uh
gp's not doing so good right now no
oh
jp that was a valiant attempt yes really
really good that was so good
so you've talked about so many new
things but when will people get to see
them right we'll get to see them
hopefully everyone will get to play in
december so very very soon that is very
soon thank you so much laura for coming
by this is all very exciting thank you
for having me let's take one last look
at some gameplay from the tower
[Applause]
once again our friends at element
animation have made us something to
enjoy and perhaps even sing along to
all while taking us through everything
you can do right now from caves and
cliffs part one try not to get this one
stuck in your head all week i only say
this because it's been stuck in mine
hey
you two
have you discovered all the features in
part one of the caves and cliffs update
there's brand new colored candles
[Music]
spending too much time in powder snow
will make you
[Music]
a lightning rod and thunderstorms will
stop you getting shot copper oxidizes
but to stop it make it waxed craft your
raw ores into roblox if you've got too
many stacks
[Music]
fill their caves with lies make a sign
using their ink make the glow frame
super bright they're stripped stone
blocks and deep slight versions of the
oars there's so many things here to
explore and there's so much
[Music]
well it's been quite the turnout for our
first round of mob voting you have made
your decision and now one mob must go we
have the glare the alley and the copper
golem but you the community have spoken
and now one mob must leave the race and
that mob is
the glare
so that still leaves two amazing mobs to
choose from which one do you want will
it be the lay or the copper golem how do
you see yourself playing and interacting
with them in the future which one will
make your game life easier or more fun
or like the year of the phantom way more
terrifying don't worry about what anyone
else wants this is all about you and how
you want to play minecraft but make your
decision quickly because it's time to
vote again there's a brand new poll just
posted to the minecraft twitter account
with only these two mob finalists to
choose from make sure you're logged onto
twitter and click the mob that you just
can't wait to spend your days and nights
with in the game
your vote really counts so don't miss
out on your chance to change minecraft
i know who i'm going to vote for and i
think i can see yen's voting right now
okay so i know this will come as a
surprise to pretty much all of you but i
definitely didn't love everything about
school maybe that would have been
different if
i had minecraft in my classes minecraft
education edition is available for
schools home schools and after school
programs you can explore awesome
education content in minecraft
marketplace
learn about everything from
sustainability to ancient worlds even
how to speak new languages all in
minecraft the coolest part is seeing how
with minecraft the students often become
the teachers
when i tried becoming the teacher in my
fifth grade science class well let's
just say it wasn't appreciated but
anyway
let's take a look at how minecraft is
being used in classrooms around the
world by kids who didn't get in trouble
just for telling everyone that homework
was canceled forever
young people all over the world are
using minecraft to explore issues that
matter like social justice climate
change and indigenous rights
we have different classes such as
braille and sign language we reached out
to one of our teachers who learned
braille and she taught us a thing or two
take a look at what these girls built a
school of the future they thought about
clean energy and inclusive design an
interesting fact about our building is
that we used coding to build a
playground it was very fun to make
students in india and malaysia
translated ancient myths into minecraft
worlds
under the guidance of my educator kamal
mam i would like to present to you an
indigenous tale chiri and ka from punjab
the land of five rivers
in canada australia and new zealand
classrooms are using minecraft to
explore indigenous cultures
and they're not just building blocks
they're building super useful skills
games like minecraft prepare you for the
future teaching us how to work together
solve problems and even write code
normally in school it's like here's this
do this off you go but now it's like
black schedule minecraft yes please
this summer students imagined a greener
new york city in an epic citywide
esports battle
i don't know about you but i wish i had
this in school i think i would have been
all over the
absolutely
kids in wales designed more sustainable
rugby stadiums
[Music]
teams of students built turtle habitats
and wind farms
and in slovakia young people imagined a
bee sanctuary in minecraft
during this build i learned that bees do
this thing called swarming
we can live more sustainably we can
treat one another better and can we all
agree that learning should always be fun
let's build a better world together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now it's the big moment let's talk to
agnes about the next update welcome back
agnes thank you how's the show felt for
you
super good like i think it's a really
fun show and also of course we've shown
so many exciting things absolutely i've
i mean i'm feeling quite nostalgic since
this is number 10 and i have to say i
was the seventh employee the first woman
on the team and when i see you leading
minecraft i just feel so excited about
where we're going
thank you
that was very sweet of you and of course
we managed to lead it together but i
like i'm like the creative lead and i'm
yeah i'm i'm super happy about that but
it feels quite surreal because you know
i also just used to be a minecraft
player and love this game and it's it's
yeah i'm very happy and lucky to be here
yes i think we all feel that way and
it's so cool having so many people on
the team who play and love it and care
about it and like we all feel like i
mean we are part of the community too
yes we definitely are and now agnes you
are going to reveal to us
what the next update is yes
okay
so the next update is called the wild
update
[Music]
the wild update sounds very very
intriguing so what does it encompass
so the word wild mainly means like two
things for us so the first thing is like
beautiful nature
and the second thing is like really
scary challenges and adventures oh that
sounds awesome and so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna have
some of our gameplay designers come and
tell us more about specific things about
the wild update because there's these
different parts to it and we have the
first one here which is our deep dark
expert brandon
hello hi brandon welcome thank you
so
we've moved the deep dark into this
update can you talk to us more about why
yes i mean one of the biggest things
about the deep dark and the water and
the skull because that it's just
expanded it's gotten bigger and we've
we really wanted to make sure that we
did this right and that we didn't just
rush it
that includes even unique loot inside
the deep dark as well
and yeah
we also want to make sure that uh we
sorry
uh let's actually look at some of the
new things that we have in it right now
which is the ancient cities
that's awesome i can't wait oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
wow it's like both beautiful and
terrifying at the same like i have so
many emotions when i look at that deep
dark biome yes i mean we really didn't
want the deep dark biome to just be you
know caves or just skulk spread around
we wanted to add a bit more mystery to
it um and you know there's this ancient
city and what is it doing there we're
not going to tell the players we're just
going to let them go throughout and
explore and see what they come to
and there's even this like
ancient structure in the middle of every
single city and it's got something
interesting about it that you're going
to have to explore in game
it's really cool i i like it feels like
a place you want to explore
yes i love that it really deepens the
mystery of minecraft like minecraft is
all about player stories and deep dark
definitely inspires storytelling i think
that's so cool and so last year you
showed us the skulk sensor but i know
you've been working on it a little skulk
family
it's a school family
yeah maybe they're not so cute not so
friendly no
yeah last year we focused a lot on the
skulk sensor but since then we've kind
of been trying to figure out what do all
the different blocks in the skulk family
do and one of them actually is something
called a skull catalyst and the main
thing about the sculpt catalyst is it's
actually what causes the sculpt to
spread
as you can see here whenever a mob dies
such as the zombie near the skull
catalyst it actually spreads skulk
underneath it and the amount is based on
how much xp that zombie would have
dropped wow so
you know the deep dark it's kind of
overgrown with all the skull flocks so
that means that lots of mobs must have
died there quite a lot yes
scary
oh and as you can see here when you mine
some of the skull
blocks you actually get enchanting
points
yes and of course if you still want to
get some of the blocks for decoration or
something you can just use a silk touch
and then we have the skull shrieker
so when this block is activated
it's gonna give that really scary shriek
sound that you heard now and it also
gives this darkness effect so it's like
pulsating darkness
even see now when you're sneaking and
you step on a skulk sensor even sneaking
it will activate wow okay definitely not
a friendly family
and i will say to our younger viewers in
a in a minute we're gonna show you a
clip that's a little scarier but i just
i mean
brandon those have so many things that
players can do with them like what do
you imagine them doing i think the skull
catalyst is going to be really
interesting because
you know when
you could create a mob farm with a like
through the tech community um
usually when mob dies it doesn't drop xp
unless you the player actually kills it
so with this you might be able to create
some sort of xp farm
there's lots of opportunities
and you can be like experiences for
other players like imagine building like
a haunted mansion or a really dark
forest and then you have the streak it's
terrifying
and then you know and players out
working and then they actually shriek
and you're like
that's amazing
you do that all around your world and
just whenever anyone's visiting i'm not
going to be with your words
shriekers are just shrieking
we have a community question for you
hi it's ginger from germany and my
question is what was the inspiration
behind the shrieker
oh yeah i mean that's an interesting
question from the art side we actually
had the inspiration behind the human
larynx which is like the vocal chord or
vocal structure or something just
something that represents kind of
creating sounds and from the gameplay
perspective we wanted to make sure that
first of all the warden spawns in a
unique way and also in a way that you
can avoid it so usually you can kind of
sneak around and as long as you don't
activate the
skull shriekers then the warden won't
come but
if you do make too many noises and the
skull shrink activates too many times
the warden will come
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm kind of back to thinking that the
skulk family is very adorable and sweet
wow there is a lot there brandon
definitely a lot to unpack i mean the
first thing is that the warden actually
emerges underground so that means you
know that wardens are kind of in the
deep dark in the walls under the floor
and it also has developed a sense of
smell so of course you can sneak around
and try to be you know quiet and not to
get detected
but unfortunately the warden's still
going to be able to sniff you out and
find where you are and if it sniffs you
while you're really close by then it's
going to start noticing you wait so
basically the warden is like
smell that it's happening and just like
going for the pretty much yes it's not
going to be fun for you no and i love
that we're adding that like
sneaking gameplay because we haven't
really had it before so you know you are
in the deep dark everything's super dark
and you're sneaking trying to find the
treasures trying to avoid warding i
think something really exciting with
that it's really really cool i mean i
think you have definitely upped the
terrifying level brandon and i just love
how much you've expanded the deep dark
to feel it's so it's so immersive yes
definitely it's really amazing thank you
so much for joining us and
and scaring us have to death no worries
that's my job yeah he's so expert like
if you want to do something scarce like
brendo
thanks brandon thank you so much
so agnes the deep dark is one part this
sort of very adventurous side of the
wild update which the name is starting
to really become clear after talking to
brandon and then the other part you said
is really this more of that beauty and
you know the atmosphere of minecraft yes
so we want to like celebrate the
wilderness of minecraft and one thing we
want to focus on is immersion so when
you play minecraft we really want you to
feel that you're inside the minecraft
world actually like we are now so
beautiful and
we also want to focus or have focus on
biome diversity
so we want to find like a unique
identity for different biomes for
example the birch forest as you can see
in this beautiful concept art so in the
bird's forest we want it to be like
light and peaceful and the sun reaches
the ground the trees are taller and the
flower flowers things like that it's
really beautiful it looks very swedish
in the birch forest that's true that's
actually very swedish forest yeah it's
gorgeous and then you have so you want
to add more atmosphere to the different
biomes but there's one biome that you
want i mean i would say you're giving it
quite an overhaul it's getting a lot
more in the wild update yes that's true
and that's the swamp
oh
our team is just so amazing it's such a
beautiful concept art and as you can see
here the atmosphere is really different
from from the birch forest as well it
really is it's amazing so we have
another one of our gameplay designers
here and our swamp expert corey welcome
corey hi corey hey it's absolutely wild
to be here oh no corey the puns are so
quick it just starts it's core after all
yeah it's very on brand
so you're going to tell us about all of
the x i mean there's a lot of exciting
things coming to the swamp so what are
we getting yes there are a lot of
awesome things coming the first of which
is the boat with the chestnut
[Music]
[Music]
it's so useful and relaxing yes and
especially now you know in keepsake part
2 we have even wider rivers so it's
easier to travel water so it's going to
be like extra useful yeah and like in
the aquifers as well yes like when you
go rafting in the case you can like put
your diamonds in the chest in your boat
oh it's really amazing and you've been
working on what i think now will be my
favorite tree in minecraft yes we are
adding the mangrove tree to minecraft
so as you can see here this is a
propagule and propagules grow from
mangrove trees they're actually like
ready to grow
uh mangrove mini mangroves growing from
the mangrove and you can see here the
mangrove tree grows propped up on root
blocks it has vines hanging down from
the leaves the propagules are actually
growing underneath the leaves they
actually grow from the leaves themselves
and i really like how the propagules are
looking here and okay i'm just going to
nerd out on tropicals
okay so in real life the propagules grow
like i said from the mangrove tree and
then when they fall into the water or
like let's say they fall into water they
could float for up to a year before they
plant themselves in the the like water
under underneath the water or on land
wherever they happen to land and
mangrove trees themselves are actually
amazing for like local ecosystems
fighting climate change for local
communities they're just super trees and
i'm really really excited that we're
adding them to minecraft that's awesome
and this is the first sapling that you
can plant underwater yeah you can plant
it underwater and on land as well that's
so cool when you first showed me the
mangroves and you talked about your
favorite thing the propagules i actually
remember playing in mangroves in florida
and we would use them to like right in
the sand because they're super cool
so seeing them in minecraft is just so
so exciting and of course
where there's a new tree there must be a
new wood type yes the mangroves do come
with a new boot type and like always
when we add a new tree we are
so happy like we get so many questions
from the community like will there be a
new wood type
and and
therefore we're so happy that we were
able to add and you would type for the
mangroves
and look at it i think it's really
pretty and you also don't see like all
the blocks here it's gonna be like a
full set for the retards they're gonna
be like doors and tractors and so on
that's gorgeous i love it
i'm like i'm so excited about mangroves
buddies need to mention another thing
because
we we decided to go with like really big
roots and i think those are so cool and
we actually prototyped quite a lot back
and forth and it was a bit tricky to
decide how the rules should look like as
you see in this picture here but now i'm
so happy that we went with the like
multi-block roots because for example
when you like go with a boat and then
you can go under the mangroves and i
think that adds such a nice feeling to
it yeah like in this picture
it's really nice it smells sorry
that's beautiful i really agree and like
when i was testing i really loved that
feeling of like being underneath it
being yeah like just this huge feeling
and i wanted more i wanted to be
surrounded by mangroves so i was like
hmm why don't i just make a mangrove
swamp biome where i'm completely
surrounded by them
so as you can see in this video walking
around you're just completely surrounded
in the mangrove swamp it's just
mangroves as far as the eye can see just
like in real life and you have all the
mangroves propped up on their roots
growing in the water so you can take
your boat underneath like agnes likes
and you're just completely surrounded by
the awesome beauty of it it's so
beautiful oh and i mean during sunset
every time i was testing i would
actually like pause the day night cycle
just to watch the sunset in the mangrove
swamp it was super beautiful
that's absolutely gorgeous
i noticed that that was not dirt
good eye lydia that was wet dirt
otherwise known as mud
that's amazing so you've actually added
mud to do something really cool yeah so
we're adding really cool renewability
mechanics to mud the first of which is
if you take a dirt block and pour a
water bottle on it then you can get more
mud and then the other one is if you
take your mud block and you stick it on
top of the drip stone it will sort of
like drip the water out of the mud and
eventually dried out which turns into
clay i love the renewable clay like i
always need more bricks so perfect yeah
your local mason isn't going to be super
happy with you though that's actually
true i i have this one mason like it's
time onto your mason in my village and i
always change with them you're taking a
villager's job they might be a bit upset
now but still renewable clay yeah it's
really really cool and you're also using
mud to make a new block yes we're also
adding mud bricks
so mud bricks are really really exciting
like building block and as you can see
here the the brick texture is actually
different than the other stone bricks
that we have in the game so they're sort
of smaller more compact but it is really
cool like to build with it matches a lot
of different block sets and i i'm really
excited to build with them
i just love the look of them they're
awesome
so beautiful we have a creator question
for the two of you
what is
i'm so excited they asked this question
because i really wanted to answer it so
the main reason that i wanted to add mud
bricks to the game is that i really
wanted people to feel like they're okay
all around the world there are houses
built out of mud bricks so many people
around the world have houses buildings
using mud bricks and i really wanted
people who are playing minecraft to feel
like they could build their home and
feel like they're at home in minecraft
so i'm really glad we got to add them
for that it's amazing yes it's so
important for us that like everyone
feels equally welcome when playing
minecraft oh that is that is absolutely
amazing now so we have
like amazing new trees we have mud
everywhere
we definitely need something very cute
yes well very cute and quite derpy
because we're adding frogs
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
they are cute and derpy that's the
perfect description of them
the croaking is amazing and did you see
the one that jumped like backwards
one fell in the water silly frogs yes
and they do like they do love to jump
around and especially on lily pads and
actually also on big drip leaves because
i mean the big drip leaves kind of look
like lily pads but the funny thing with
that is then when they jump on top of
the big drip leaves it's gonna tilt and
then they fall down one of them did it
just
maybe it's a like frog slide
[Laughter]
and you're adding another little little
tiny creature to this update yes the
fireflies
so you can see them
roaming around adding a lot of ambience
to the swamp
making it feel just nice and cozy at
night but really
my favorite part of them is just making
the world come to life like feeling like
there is life going on all around you
and
oh yeah also their frog food
yeah i forgot to mention that they're
frog food
for fireflies yeah but look how happy
that frog is yeah and they're beautiful
frog food so you can both enjoy them in
the atmosphere and the frogs get to eat
so that's you know
now
we're calling them fireflies but cory is
that what you called them growing up
actually no we called them lightning
bugs i did too and in swedish it's it's
el deflogor and that's actually
literally translates to fireflies okay
it's very interesting it became like a
lot of people talking about what you
called it growing up but we're really
excited to have fireflies or lightning
bugs
in the game
i want to know more about baby frogs
yes so you know old baby mobs in
minecraft i used like tiny versions of
the grown ups but with frogs we're
actually adding tadpoles
[Applause]
once again you deliver on the promise of
cute and derpy with the tadpoles
yes and you can pick them up in a bucket
yes and that's actually extra helpful
for the tadpoles because we have frog
variants and when a tadpole grows up it
will pick a variant depending on the
temperature in the biome it grows up in
so for example if it grows up in a
really cold place it's going to turn
into a snowy frog
yeah as you can see here so
the frogs have came like two main
systems one is the tadpole system and
the other one is the cold-blooded system
so frogs are like the first cold-blooded
animal in minecraft
and in real life there actually are frog
variants that pick a color
depending on like or they adapt their
color depending on temperature and we
wanted to have that minecraft we wanted
to like minecraftify it so therefore the
tadpole is going to pick a variant
instead depending on on the temperature
that's so cool and there are three
variants there's gonna be three okay so
we've seen two what's the third one the
third one is the tropical frog
so let's say you were venturing out into
the desert or the jungle and you take
your your tadpole with you and if it
grows up there it'll turn into a lovely
tropical frog and what i really love
about the tropical frogs is how just
relaxed they look and they're like
blending into the sand almost they're
just so relaxed
just chilling there yeah
yes and i think there was a reason that
they were yes
there is a reason that they are white so
like i was reading a lot about frogs
always maybe that's something we read up
a lot it's super fun because we can be
really geeky
and then i learned about the real-life
frog that's called gray foam nest tree
frogging leaves for example in angola
botswana in kenya and that frog can
actually turn almost white to avoid
overheating so that's like the
inspiration for the tropical frog in
minecraft i love all three of them and
you didn't so you have these different
color variations but you also have
something else special about the frogs
yes so each frog variants can have
something unique that will be useful for
the players but we actually don't even
know what that is yet because we're
working on the frogs right now
that is so cool so corey
which frog is your favorite
oh it's gotta be the snowy frog it looks
so cozy oh i'm i'm tropical frog i'm
very interested to see which one the
community loves the most i love them all
of them yeah exactly thank you so much
for joining us corey and taking us into
a deep dive of all really cool swamp
things yeah happy to be here thank you
corey thank you for everything he's
going to hop on out of here
bye chloe many proms
i like that though
this is quite an awesome update and i
mean i really see the name for the wild
update you get a bit of everything in it
yes and i love the contrast yes you can
see in this pretty concept art it's
really like that beautiful nature and
the super terrifying deep dark and i
love that contrast between these two
things it's absolutely amazing
well we're getting close to the end of
the show and as always the time has
flown by
and a lot has happened during this show
so let's look back at some of the
biggest announcements and then we will
reveal the winning mob
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
now it's time to see what mom you chose
to add to the game uh hey jens do you
have the results yes i have them right
here in my chest
wow really exciting you really came in
style
there you go thank you so much that
looked really comfortable
okay but now it's time to announce the
winner
okay and the winner is
the lay
wow
yes i'm super happy about that it's a
lovely lovely mom
that is so so exciting so agnes
when can everyone expect the la so the
la will be included in the wind update
and it's going to be released next year
next year the wild update with the la
i can't wait
thank you all so much for joining us
minecraft wouldn't be what it is today
without all of you from all of us at
mojang studios thank you so much bye
[Music]
cows
[Music]
you